cops are on the way
in the next generation of battlefield
take the fight to the streets as cops
and criminals go head-to-head
an explosive urban firefighter
my strategy speed and story is the
fastest and most innovative battlefield
yet
this is battlefield hardline strategy
has always been a staple of the
Battlefield franchise and hardline is no
exception
coordinated tactics and communication
are essential on both sides that law
take on the role of an operator mechanic
enforcer or professional each with its
own unique loadouts and abilities in
addition hardline features over 30 new
gadgets and weapons like the compressed
gas launch grappling hook which can
change the dynamic of any engagement
or unleash the new zipline crossbow to
get into the action even faster
it stops ballistic shields are your best
friend during intense firefight but they
won't protect you from a gang of
criminals on the sledge hammers and
Molotov cocktails
whichever side you're on seek out one of
the lethal battle pickups even
throughout the map and gain the upper
hand
support your squad with gadgets like the
tracer dart gun and laser tripmine
or even the new T 60 to stun-gun
Altima takedown and be sure to use hard
lines of disruption to your advantage
or our try hacker mode to take over the
environments and play puppet master with
your enemies
hardline is the fastest battlefield yet
with tighter maps faster player movement
higher powered gadgets and a wide
variety of new vehicles built for the
urban environment all new modes like
Hotwire will test your reflexes on
high-speed missions to boost rides or
chase them down then in the frenetic
high-stakes rescue mode criminal forces
hold civilians hostage while SWAT team
members must fight to set them free card
lines on their rides accelerate the
action of the agile choppers airboats
motorcycles and muscle cars
hop out of the window to get a clean
shot on your enemy or grab one of your
vehicles stored weapons to get rid of a
pesky tail and try and nitrous powered
stunt vehicle to get out of trouble fast
taking cues from the modern crime drama
hardman story comes to life in a
gripping single-player experience that
unfolds in an all new episodic TV style
campaign you do trust Oz right partner
she's in trouble
that means we help the players journey
follows Nick Mendoza a Cuban American
and the newest member of Miami's vice
squad along with his partner hi a brassy
Krav Maga expert Nick is charged with
breaking up a prolific and brutal drug
ring that is ravaging the streets of
Miami applause I had everything on a
platter and you [ __ ] it up the suit
extends far beyond the city limits from
the palatial Florida Keys up through the
deadly Everglades and all the way to the
mean streets of Los Angeles
Nick hold them off while I do some
triage there's guns in the truck keep
your skills sharp
by taking on seven additional cases that
go above and beyond the main story line
that's nine point nine million dollars
worth of coke uh what are you drunk Rain
Man use the scanner to uncover clues
from suspects execute arrest warrants on
wanted felons searched for valuable
Intel the crime story continues on in
hard lines multiplayer with nine unique
locations jump into 64 player classic
modes like conquest or try any of the
brand-new fast-paced modes like heist
blood money and crosshair hostage
situations drug wars high-speed pursuits
and massive urban battles are just the
beginning of the endless crime wave and
multiplayer whichever side of the law
you're on hard lines combination of
strategy speed and story is designed to
deliver the ultimate cop and criminal
experience
only in battlefield hardline